welcome back
i'm outside the cbs broadcast center on
the busy streets of new york city and
it's
all to celebrate our next guest
stephanie stanky a mechanic who at 29
joined a small list of women who own
automotive
repair shops she's our latest wildflower
and empowering other women to learn more
about cars really revs my
engine stephanie is joining us now
hi stephanie how are you i'm doing so
well thank you so much for having me i
i really admire you how are you i feel
the exact same way about you stephanie
you've made it your mission to empower
other women
to learn more about cars will you
explain
absolutely so it's it's been a struggle
working in this field
um it's something that i absolutely love
doing it's my passion
but throughout the years you know i've
had to deal with a lot of struggles with
the things people have said with the
things people have done with
the lower pay that's been offered and i
can only imagine that's what consumers
feel like too especially women that
want to take their vehicles in so that's
something that we're working towards to
try to create you know a better
environment for women that do want to
work in this field especially going
forward
and i've had to create my own
opportunities to do that wow
i really respect what you just said and
it makes all the sense in the world and
i thank you for
bringing that out into the spotlight
because i love when women do
what men do i love when men do what
women do
it should all be equal opportunity and
the pay
should be equal as well now
i feel like i'm a bad cliche stephanie
because i know
if i broke down on the side of the road
i
wouldn't know who to call i would feel
helpless
and most importantly i would be scared
and the best way to conquer fear
is to fix it figure it out and learn
so i'm really excited about not only
shining a light on the important things
that you're doing
but learning how to empower myself
because it is all about rescuing
yourself whether you're a man or a woman
so
show me how to do this so that
i can know what to do in this situation
absolutely the best way to feel
comfortable and confident when you have
your own car is just to know kind of how
to do some of those basics yourself
so today i'm going to show you how to
jump start a battery
by using a portable jump pack so if you
ever get stuck on the side of the road
you don't have to rely on strangers to
do that you don't have to hope that
whoever stops you know you don't have to
worry about who they are as a person
you can find them at any local parts
store you can find them online
portable dump packs come with a variety
of features but they're usually within
like the 80 to you know 150
range um that you can find a really good
one that you can leave in your car
so the first thing that we're going to
do we're just going to actually identify
on the car what you want to be looking
for first
so to get started you're going to want
to identify which one
is your positive and which one is your
negative
so usually the positive has a red
you know cable a red cover all right
that's pretty clear plus red positive
got it all right thank you so
you want to make sure you watch for any
jewelry any
you know anything that you could have
dangling you don't want anything
crossing first
you know so you make sure that you know
you've got everything out of your
workspace so
you want to look for the red clip first
you're going to always connect the
positive
first okay so i've got it on there so
then you're going to want to connect
black cable and make sure that you have
a solid connection on there they're not
flopping around
not falling over you just want to clamp
it on there pretty quickly
so then with the jump pack that we have
you're going to want to go ahead
and turn that on there's just this power
button right there
you want to make sure to turn that on
hold down for just a second there
when it's charged okay so what's next do
i
finally go to start the dead vehicle
you're gonna go ahead
and start your vehicle first
okay so i'm gonna start it are you ready
it started stephanie perfect
so you just want to let it run for a
minute just so the alternator can keep
recharging your battery
and then once you're ready to come back
up front
um okay so how long do i let it run for
usually you just let it run two to five
minutes depending if it if
a real quick uh jump jumpstart you know
you really gotta get out of there i mean
you do want to
make sure once you do start it you you
do let it run after that and drive it
you don't just shut it right back off
right away you want to let it recharge a
bit
before you drive you do want to take it
back off so you want to let it run for
you know maybe that five minute mark
first and then we're gonna go right
ahead and turn it back off
okay i mean it was like
simple logic turn off the thing that's
sending electric currents
ah okay oh that was just me nothing
happened
okay so when you do take it off you
actually want to start by taking off
your negative cable first but
i did i did i did yes i
did okay but that's important start by
taking the
negative cable off first so get rid of
the bad vibes
take off the negative like
hone in on the positive then remove that
second
and isn't it funny that you can conquer
your fear just by getting on top of it
and figuring it out
here is the solve you are my hero and
i'm wondering stephanie
i also don't know how to change a tire
on the side of the road would you be
willing to come
back on the show and teach me how to do
that
i would love to do that i would be so
happy to teach you that
okay me too i literally was like what's
more important the battery or the tire
how about we do both and help everybody
exactly all right we're going to put
these instructions on the drewberrymore
show.com
and thank you stephanie thank you for
empowering me
to rescue myself
[Music]